you differentiate between equity and
equality
well the quality we talk about uh
I don't know what the answer to that is
coming to think of it you know uh
equality is equality of opportunity all
right we live in a society we want all
people right to have whatever color your
skin is equity I think is more guarantee
of outcome is it not
okay I think so I think that's okay so
which view come which side do you come
down on
all equality equality yeah okay
if you have any roughly approximately
sane Lefty in your family and they still
think Bernie is good or Bernie knows
what he's talking about show them that
clip he does not know the basics
this has got to end
we need Equity all equality equality
yeah okay
[Music]
oh
Reuben it's March 7th
2023. I'm Dave Rubin once again this is
the Reuben report we're very excited
we're live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals we crushed every live stream
record yesterday things are going well
over here and that cold open was a
little YouTube short that we're doing
every day we're doing one or two of them
every single day if you're watching on
the YouTube although we do want you to
watch on Rumble of course rumble.com
Reuben report but YouTube is heavily
pushing these shorts so we're putting
plenty of them up there that's one of
them and we have a shelf if you just go
to youtube.com Reuben report there's a
shelf you can click shorts and see all
the shorts that we are putting up there
if you want to join us at the end of the
show today for our post game wrap up you
can join us at
reubenreport.locals.com and yes
yesterday not only crushed it on the
live stream numbers but it was our
longest show ever some say the best work
that Dave Rubin has ever done some are
saying it I'm not saying who I'm just
saying some people are saying it okay so
we're going to continue where we left
off yesterday a little bit of the woke
stuff a little bit of what's going on
with Hollywood and the cultural shifts
that are happening right before our eyes
because I really think that this Russell
Brand moment that now you've all seen
probably multiple times
him on Real Time with uh with Bill Maher
and sitting there with this MSNBC hack
this guy John heilman uh and really
laying down some truth and watching just
sort of a product of the machine this
this heilman guy just crumble under it I
think the red pilling is happening it's
happening with more celebrities Chris
Rock has a new Netflix special out which
was stolen out some red pills we'll show
you a couple clips and I think it's even
leaking into corporations right now so
the worm might be turning but you must
give the devil his due and somehow every
time we think we're getting a win you
know it's two steps forward three steps
back with this thing so we got to just
keep the pressure on and see what's what
but let's get right to it today so Chris
Rock You Know Comedian Chris Rock uh he
dropped a new Netflix comedy special
back in my day everybody wanted an HBO
Comedy Special that was the thing if you
were doing stand-up you wanted an HBO
Comedy Special that was the place to do
it I don't know that HBO's doing as much
these days so Netflix seems to be the
place that people want to get their
specials out although if I if I may for
just a moment my special don't say Dave
which was shot live in Orlando the end
of the don't burn this country tour the
show that I did with Governor DeSantis
it was basically completely unscripted a
few things that I had done uh previously
on the tour that is available for all
local subscribers annual subscribers
that is or I think it's 10 bucks if you
want to do the one-time deal look we've
put a link down there that was can we do
that again if I just point will it show
up watch
wow that was pretty good all right
anyway Chris Rock has a new Netflix
special and uh he's going after the woke
he's going after the false cries of
racism he's going after the cancel
culture machine and the whole thing uh
here's a little clip going after Meghan
Markle for playing the race card she
went through was not racism
it was just some in-laws
cause she's complaining I'm like what
the is talking about nope they're
so racist they wanted to know how Brown
the baby was gonna be they're so racist
they wanted to know how Brown the baby's
gonna be I'm like that's not racist
because even black people want to know
[Applause]
how Brown the baby gonna be that's
pretty funny like rock is a solid comic
he did some stuff about the Will Smith
slap and and a bunch more I'm going to
show you one more clip of rock but
what's interesting about that is you
really gotta understand when when this
Meghan Markle Prince Harry thing which
we've covered a little bit here and you
guys know my feelings on this like I
don't think that we have to focus too
much on you know the Royals of another
country uh but somehow because
culturally these things are now all
connected and we live in this globalist
world whether we like it or not you know
what happens there affects us here and
what happens here affects them across
the pond and you know when when they
sell a book or whatever it might be get
a TV show a special on Netflix uh
they're on every channel right they're
pushed on the front of every magazine
and everything else so whether you like
these things or not or care about these
things or not they sort of care about
you because they become part of the
cultural stuff that we're all kind of
stuck in the muck and the mire that
we're all constantly in the La Brea Tar
Pits of culture lunacy but what's
interesting is we all knew it it was
like you really think that at the end of
the day
that more than anything else that the
royal family is racist like and that she
came in I mean this is what really the
important thing about this is that
Prince Harry let her into the family and
she has done more in in like two years
to destroy the institution of the
monarchy than probably anybody including
when the king you know two generations
ago abdicated the throne because he
didn't want the pressure that kind of
hurt them a little bit but she has
infected them with wokism and it's a
it's a huge problem
even if you think that a monarchy is
completely ridiculous and none of this
makes any sense and again it's not on
our Shores why should we care from an
American perspective
the institutions that have existed for
thousands and thousands of years that
were watching crumble whether it's
thousands of years or hundreds of years
if there are education institutions or
entertainment institutions whatever it
is it's like they can all crumble but
unless we're going to build something
better afterwards we're gonna we're
gonna crumble along with them but Rock
kept going I really enjoyed this bit
he's going after the left because
they're always equating words to
violence Remember Violence isn't
violence if you burn down to Pep Boys in
the name of black lives matter that's
somehow not violence if you punch an
Asian store owner and steal some salami
sandwiches that's all good
but words are the things you've really
got to watch out for words
[Music]
says words hurt
has never been punched in the face
it's true being punched in the face and
I've been punched in the face once or
twice in my day much worse than words
when people say mean things to me on
Twitter I'm like oh no but punched in
the face
not the most fun thing in the world but
as I said we take two steps forward and
then we seem to take two steps two three
steps back right sometimes I guess it's
two steps back and we're just sort of
where we started and then sometimes
usually it seems like we fall backwards
a little bit which is why I always talk
about that slow descent to hell that
we're on with these people because while
it is great that Chris Rock is now out
there and seemingly in in the red pilled
Camp so let's call this like The Joe
Rogan Camp of Comedy or now the Russell
Brand camp or or quasi Bill Maher you
know it's like the somewhat relevant
interesting edgy comedians are now in
this Camp so that that really is great
but when I talk about the three-step
back thing the machine isn't just gonna
acquiesce just like that is going to
keep going so I saw this headline from
Washington Post and an interesting op-ed
uh perspective as the governor fights
diversity and inclusion in Florida Major
League Baseball should take a stand
Kevin B blackestone right so now here's
a little bit from the piece this is
Kevin blackistone who I used to think
was pretty decent guy he was on that
show around the horn remember Kevin
Blackstone on around the horn on ESPN
but he's going all in on Race here you
go baseball can no longer ignore Ron
desantis's culture wars if baseball is
still concerned with as much it's 15
franchises that started spring training
last month in Florida should consider
making the annual exercise and all
Cactus League Affair as long as DeSantis
commands an attack on diversity it has
been the Hallmark of his governorship
which many believe is a prologue to a
presidential bid just last month
DeSantis called a new advanced placement
high school course in African-American
studies indoctrination dismissed its
educational value and threatened to
replace the non-profit college board
that approved it and about a year ago
DeSantis signed into law the don't say
gay bill so nicknamed by critics who
prohibits which prohibits public schools
from T any teaching on sexual
orientation or gender identity unless
they are considered age-appropriate or
development or developmentally
appropriate yet a league that started
celebrating Pride several months ago is
deeply rooted this time of year in
Florida the teams could remind DeSantis
of the 2018 study that estimated spring
training injected 687 million dollars
into the state a little more than six
weeks over a little more than six weeks
okay guys first off let's just go
through the nonsensical lies as you know
the don't say gay thing the word gay
isn't in it this was about parental
rights and education it was about age
appropriate stuff so for some reason
this guy Kevin blackistone wants State
teachers to teach talk to six-year-olds
about gender and sexuality that's a
little weird to me but okay that's what
he wants as far as the removing the AP
African-American studies course as you
know it also included gender theory in
it which has nothing to do with
African-American studies he's not
denying anyone from learning about civil
rights or slavery so you guys know all
that stuff right so we don't have to
smack you over the head with that but
he's just lying and that's all they do
and they do it in the name of We're the
good guys because we care about
diversity so I was thinking about it
well baseball diversity diversity in
baseball could I get the numbers and we
checked the numbers so I want to break
down some ethnic numbers in baseball
before even to have to say that is so
stupid nobody in sports cares about the
ethnicity of anyone can you hit the ball
can you throw the ball can you dunk the
ball can you catch the ball that's what
we oh Mike was that a white guy that
caught that when nobody cares anyway
here's the ethnic breakdown in Major
League Baseball it's 58 percent white uh
32 percent Hispanic and 7.8 percent
black now we've got a problem here Kevin
blackistone because you really want
diversity and no doubt when someone says
they want diversity that means they want
Equity they want equal outcomes which is
the most anti-human thing that there is
because it takes away everything that
you are as an individual and just you
know cordons you off as your skin color
or sexuality or gender or whatever uh so
white people in the in America are 76 so
what was the number on white people in
baseball it was like 50 58 so white
people are under represented in Major
League Baseball we have got to get more
white people playing Major League
Baseball and I want to give a shout out
right now to Connor Connor
played second base High School baseball
Arizona state champions what year
2011. you've got a chance man I mean
you're doing fine around here I'm not
saying you should go and get another job
but I'm just saying we need more white
people you're the whitest guy in the
room
even though he's been living in Florida
for a year he seems to be getting paler
it's weird we don't know what's going on
a Daphne's actually pretty pale too
no offense no offense anyway uh Hispanic
people are 32 percent in baseball okay
so 32 percent of MLB players are
Hispanic but only 19 in the general
population we must remove the gonzales's
we must remove the Ramirez's and the
cruises and the others okay it's too
many Hispanics we we believe in equity
and diversity uh black people
7.8 percent of MLB players are black and
14 of Americans are black so black
people we could up we could up the black
people in ml baseball maybe they're
playing basketball instead you know I'd
have to check the numbers anyway the
point is the machine will not stop like
Washington Post will keep writing these
stupid things so you've got here you've
got Chris Rock like telling you the
truth about the nonsense about fake
racism and all of this stuff and then
you have Washington Post which is owned
by Jeff Bezos
publishing these nonsensical articles
making it seem like there is anything
racist or bigoted or or otherwise
happening in Florida and it just simply
is not true but what I want to contrast
this with is that some corporations
while the Washington Post has chosen
their Road right their road is to go
fully woke some corporations are
actually going in the other direction
you may remember the last couple days
we've played a few clips of Kevin
O'Leary Shark Tank Mr Wonderful Kevin
O'Leary who's a major major in investor
has invested hundreds of millions of
dollars into I'm sure hundreds of
different companies and he's been really
pushing this idea that it is at this
point if you are an investor if you are
a Creator if you are a Founder it is
basically impossible to do those things
in a blue State because of high taxes
High regulation Etc uh well now
interestingly uh JP Morgan Chase you've
heard of Chase Bank their CEO Jamie
Diamond this is a guy who Joe Biden
often refers to as his friend and
advisor well now he even is admitting
that Florida and Texas they're doing
something right when it comes to
business and that New York ain't looking
so good these days
we've loved Florida we're growing in
Florida left and right you know small
businesses large companies I'm on my way
to Tampa we've got you know major
operations there Orlando major
operations we're opening branches and so
the mayor just joined us at a small
business event we did here we're very
pro pro Florida if you were running the
state you know you should be thinking
how can I make this date off go to well
off my people so Florida likes business
they want you to come you know you come
to Florida you see the opt-in Texas is
the same way you know if I was some
other states I mean think about why do
people like going to these dates it's
their taxes is there a pro-business they
want better life for the people it's not
necessary it's something to pause to
talk about so um you know we now have
more employees in Texas than in New York
state
you know it should have been that way
but Texas loves to be there and when you
go there they're optimistic they're
optimistic here pro-american optimistic
Pro business no unfortunately no
I I don't know that I could have said
that better myself first off the fact
that chase now has more employees in
Texas than in New York is absolutely
wild New York for the last 100 plus
years I mean since the industrial
revolution has been the center of
Finance obviously the United States but
really the entire world and people are
fleeing I mean I'm telling you after
being in New York City for the last
couple days and I was in Midtown I
didn't go all the way down down to Wall
Street but I was in Midtown which has
tons of high-rises with massive
buildings of people that used to do
business and there were no business
people on the street anymore there are
no people in suits even collar open
shirts they're just not out there it's a
bunch of people in hoodies who all smell
like weed and everyone's up to no good
that's what's happening in New York City
right now and you know he's he's talking
about it Diamond obviously from a
financial situation so he's talking
about employment he's talking about
regulations he's talking about taxes but
then it's also about all of the other
stuff that when you move to a place that
allows you to come in and create what
you want to create create you start
being happier you start actually being
friendlier your community starts being
safer because you have people who kind
of know each other and say hi to each
other I'm telling you I say hi to more
people on an average day walking my dog
here then I would say to hi to in a
month in LA because people would be
running the opposite direction because
of covet and masks and dogs can't sniff
each other and all the craziness so
there is a culture
there is a culture of freedom and
success that is happening right here and
now you can see the Divide so what I'm
trying to show you so Washington Post is
going one way Florida's evil and
diversity the guy's racist and blah blah
blah and then you have people who are
doing real business like the head of
Chase okay you may have your own
frustrations which Ace Chase is doing a
bunch with Dei so I'm not telling you
that they're all perfect but the point
is Chase knows a little something about
business and Banking and how the world
works and they are expunging themselves
from New York and going to the free
states and I'm telling you this trend is
going to continue where we will keep
seeing the Washington posts and the
msnbc's go down one route but then we
will see the people who want to create
and the states that they want to create
in flourish and go down another route so
here's Glenn yunkin Glenn young
obviously is the governor of Virginia
one in what was thought to be a race he
was definitely going to lose but
completely went against the woke stuff
right he started going hey you can't
talk about gender and all this nonsense
with our kids the parents got behind him
he ends up eating Terry McAuliffe the
Democrat who everybody thought he was
going to win and junkin's kind of
feeling good about things right now so
he went on CNBC which is a big corporate
News Channel and uh he went against the
CCP and against China because they're
trying to buy up all the Farmland in
Virginia and he ain't gonna have it what
we've seen is the CCP and the Chinese
government become much more aggressive
about progressing their strategy which
is to dominate the world let's just be
clear and they're going to do it at the
United States expense and they're using
every Arsenal element that they have
from military coercion to economic
coercion to surveillance and and it's
showing up everywhere and yes in our own
in our own Farmland I mean we have the
Pentagon we have Quantico we have the
largest naval base in the world we have
Wallops Island that's launching Rockets
uh 10 times a year and they're
surrounded by Farmland in some certain
case not pentagon is that the formula
land they're interested in and we're not
going to allow these Bad actors to buy
this Farmland it was bipartisan isn't
that all we've ever asked for right what
do I always say about DeSantis he's just
saying enough you know people like
DeSantis is playing the culture War but
DeSantis is actually just stopping the
culture war is on the way right the
rampaging Army from Hell the culture War
army is coming and then the santis is
going no can't come in here here we got
a door we got a wall you're not going to
do this in Florida right that's exactly
what Junkin is doing and the fact that
he is saying to China you will not buy
up all of our land do you guys think
it's a little bizarre that Bill Gates is
the largest Farmland owner in the United
States and China is trying to buy up
land all over the United States by the
way Florida is also in the midst of
passing a bill I think it's in the house
right now and they have super majority
so it's going to get happening it's
going to work to get China to stop
buying farmland and other properties uh
here right like we need to take this
stuff seriously but clearly the federal
government isn't going to do it so why
else is this blue and red State divide
happening it's not just the policies
right like we can all look at the
policies low taxation versus high
taxation support police don't support
the police uh we're gonna not have
open-air drug markets we are going to
have open-air drug markets it's also the
red air rhetoric around this and
unfortunately the mainstream media the
corporate press they cannot stop
themselves that's why a guy like John
heilman this MSNBC nobody that's why he
got flattened by Russell Brand because
Russell Brand exists online right he
exists in the real world he takes in a
whole bunch of different information not
saying he's right about everything I've
got him on the show tomorrow we're doing
it live at locals oh no we're not going
to air it live right we're going to hold
it we might hold it for a day or two but
we're taping it live and we will not
edit any of it I promise you that but we
just have enough stuff coming out this
week but but we'll talk about some of
our differences but the point is Russell
is a thoughtful interesting person so
what happens is when a carbon cutout
when an NPC a non-playable character
from a woke corporate entity like MSNBC
has to go against a real person the real
person just can just eat them alive
because he's got actual facts and
heilman oh but we don't lie on MSNBC yes
you damn well do we got more on that in
just a second but the point is that the
media is always feeding this divide
right this is why I show you these clips
of The View and of MSNBC and all these
things because they keep lying like
think about it somebody at the
Washington Post let's hear Jeff Bezos if
you're watching today Jeff you own the
Washington Post you are the world's
second or third richest man you bought
this newspaper it's very citizen can
like of you right you bought this
newspaper and now you publish op-eds
from people that you know are are lying
to your own
uh readers to you so the people that are
paying for this newspaper but you don't
mind that you don't mind that that's
something that you actually like so I
would say at this point the the job of
these people is to lie and speaking of
people whose job it is to lie uh here is
uh we gotta do it here we go it's the
view don't worry I don't think we're
giving well there's going to be a little
bit of whoopee maybe at some point but
here's Anna Navarro
Anna Navarro who once was a republican
she was a conservative I think she was
Marco Rubio's campaign manager years ago
if I'm not mistaken right it was
campaign manager or publicist yeah uh
here she is just lying about Trump and
DeSantis and everything happening in
Florida and freedom and all of the stuff
go it's not you know it's not just Trump
the when he's saying I'm your Warrior I
think he's saying I'm your Warrior not
fighting everybody he's fighting I'll
tell you who's fighting let me answer
you he's fighting transgenders drag
queen he's writing drag queens he's
fired you know they're fighting black
history they're fighting proof they're
fighting facts they're fighting science
that's what they're fighting
but I think that that doesn't matter
Sonny it's about it's about manufactured
culture wars it's not about logic it's
let's make things up that enrage people
that aggrieve people that piss people
off that make them feel oppressed that
make them feel like they're fear of a
loss I'm going to make them feel that
I'm going to fight for them and Rhonda
Sanchez is saying the same thing and
there was something you know the the
entire Republican party because it's
happening in so many states is is taking
this manufactured cultural War way
manufactured culture War that's a good
one
I wish I had come up with that one
because that's pretty much what she's
doing but let's just go into so you guys
get it right you know she's she's just
lying and she's again the culture war is
coming to us none of us were screaming
about drag queens or transgender
anything we were all over the race stuff
nobody thought any being racist was cool
or any of this stuff you guys have done
this so again it's just you just need
the mirror right like if you looked at
yourself in the mirror you might see who
the real racist is but real quick just
to go through some of the things she
said so so Trump and DeSantis and the
Republicans they're the ones going after
transgender people first off I don't
know anyone that is saying that an adult
transgender person doesn't have the
right to live however they wish once you
are 18 if you wish to put on a tutu as a
300 pound man and become a ballerina God
bless you we're not going to show an
image of it that's one thing then
they're going after drag queens well
they're not going after drag queens who
are performing for adults in nightclubs
as has been happening in America for
probably a hundred years they're going
after drag queens which is a hyper
sexual performance in front of children
and generally speaking that is thought
of as wrong right but these are the same
people who want third graders to have
books about getting hand jobs and how to
give hand jobs and then if you ban that
book they tell you that you're racist or
something like that then she of course
said they're going after blacks of
course they're not going after blacks we
already did this nonsense related to the
AP course they're going after history no
it's you guys with the made up history
1619 project Etc they're going after
truth well that's a real doozy
considering we just finished three years
of covid and you people lied about
mandates and you'll about lied about
social distancing and masks and vaxes
and everything else they're going after
facts yeah we'll ask these people what
gender is someone who has a penis and
then tell me who's screwing up the facts
around here and then science I mean same
one on that so it's every single thing
and again Anna I am told that you live
within like two miles of me lady we're
gonna see each other at some point
you've called me racist on Twitter I
think you're a but I'll buy you a
drink you're probably gonna throw it in
my face she'd probably throw it in my
face that's what would end up happening
but I would buy her a drink and see what
happens but you know but it's odd that
she lives in Florida isn't that funny
isn't that funny she lives in This
Racist homophobic transphobic what is
she doing down here or could it be
come with me on this one this is just
I'm just I'm spitballing right now could
it be that Florida is actually the best
place literally in the world to live if
you want to live however you want to
live and if you want to have a little
more money in your pocket and you want
to enjoy the nice weather and you want
to be around happy people and all of
those things because it's funny she's on
The View but she hasn't made New York
her permanent residence do we know how
much Anna Navarro makes on The View can
we find that out because she's got to
make a couple million a year on The View
you'd imagine because she believes in
big government even though she pretends
that she used to be a conservative or
something you would think she would want
to give New York some of those taxes but
let's say she makes three million bucks
a year on The View you know she that 10
percent that she would pay to the state
I guess she doesn't want to give that
300 000 wage I'm very confused about
Anna Navarro because she's a wonderful
wonderful woman who she makes eight she
only makes 800 Grand a year on that show
well I guess it's a sliding scale of
depending on Talent anyway here she is
with uh more lying and going off on my
friend this time is a friend of mine you
guys know Michael Knowles from
the daily wire well he gave a speech at
CPAC and uh he went all in on the
transgender stuff I want to clean up a
little bit of what he said after uh but
here she is with a very selectively
edited portion of the speech the the
entire Republican party because it's
happening in so many states is is taking
this manufactured cultural War way too
far one of the speakers at CPAC and I
think we have the clip so you hear his
words so he doesn't sue me so you hear
his words not mine go right ahead please
transgenderism must be eradicated from
public life entirely the whole
Preposterous ideology
so this is you know this is now the
train they're on right let's go after
transgender people let's go after lgbtq
and it's it's it's going to wind up
getting somebody hurt and it needs to
stop and listen if you are against your
children going to a drag show don't take
your children to a drag show no
five-year-old can drive themselves and
the number one cause of death in
children is Firearms so if you really
are concerned about your children and
their security pass some common sense
gun reform and leave the drag queens the
hell alone first off she said
manufactured again like that's again
we're probably getting demonetized
because of her but it's all right it's
all right it's like lady manufactured
nothing you shirt
her whole Persona is manufactured I'll
tell you that much they're also not
going against lgbtq people down here
it's so stupid do you know that when we
got down here the governor and his wife
literally sent us baby clothing like you
people are absolutely ridiculous you
know as for uh Knowles's comments if
you're interested in what he said or you
thought it was a little bit over the top
and I and I think to some degree he he
was really going to push the buttons
there as far as I know and I don't want
to put words in Noel's mouth but I'll
gladly let's let's get him on the show
maybe next week we can discuss this with
him or we'll get him on a Friday panel
as far as I know when he's talking about
the the transgender ideology what he's
talking about is all of the stuff that
is leaking into the schools and leaking
into all of our institutions and that
you have to deny science so when he's
saying that's the project we must in
essence destroy that's what he's talking
about I have never never once heard him
say anything about an adult person who
just wishes to dress as they wish or do
whatever they want with their body he
maybe I'm wrong on that uh and that
would be an interesting place to have a
conversation right that would be an
honest place for two people to have a
conversation me on the more libertarian
side of it which is like you gotta live
live your life I I have no right to put
my morals on you but the state does have
some uh right to do something when it
comes to the the defense of children
also isn't it interesting that Navarro
she takes the exact same talking point
that Jon Stewart was doing yesterday
when we showed you that clip of Jon
Stewart where it's like drag queens
obviously refined because more kids are
killed by guns and it's like these
things have literally nothing to do with
each other and if you're if your
prescription then is okay we're upset
that a lot of children are killed by
guns or a certain amount of children are
killed by guns obviously nobody wants
that their answer is let's take the guns
away but you're not going to believe
this guys generally bad people don't
just do gun buyback programs but the bad
people if you put up a sign and it says
no guns in this area bad people are the
ones that bring the guns in not the good
guys we also have something called the
Second Amendment I know his lefties
they're not really into it and now I
sort of Lie to everybody we do have to
show you something with Whoopi it's not
much it's not much but believe this is
wild this is absolutely wild until
yesterday guys
the audience at the view those clapping
seals who they sit down they throw them
fish heads out of a bucket I've seen it
happen I've been to the show a couple
times the warm-up guy he throws some
fish heads at them and they eat the fish
and they clap like seals and that whole
thing some of them can do tricks and
whatever
until yesterday
they have been wearing masks they were
mandated imagine what it would be like
guys to sit in a room have to watch
Whoopi Goldberg Anna Navarro Joy Behar
Sonny Hosten and that other lady
imagine having to watch them for an hour
while wearing a mask
cruel and unusual punishment that's what
I'm saying there were people on death
row that would say take me out now I'll
skip the last meal okay but they finally
took their masks off yesterday what's
today's date I want to get this
completely right
today is March 7th that 2023 thank you
very much that means yesterday was March
6 2023 okay that's when they took the
masks off
holy sheep video
look at y'all sit up here with no masks
on I know
wait a minute now
so I'm I'm talking and in my mind I'm
going what is different about this
audience see people's favorite and then
it hits me no Mass because I saw your
smile and I saw your teeth it was like
great well yeah we're getting back to
where we
all right
[Music]
like how did these clowns
these the fact that they sat there they
were willing to sit and spit on each
other because you have no doubt that
Whoopi she's a human whoopee cushion you
know there's a lot of liquid coming out
of there that she's spitting all over
these women and and and they sit there
and do their thing for the last couple
years but they kept the audience like
that because they are the elites they
are better than you that's how the
corporate machine works but let's
continue talking about how to expose
these people because that that really is
the theme if more and more of them get
exposed and we get more and more of
those Russell Brand sort of seminal
cultural moments uh then more and more
people will wake up will we still take
those three steps back at times at times
absolutely but there's a chance so I
want to show you something because this
Jonathan heilman guy so this is the guy
who Russell smacked around uh well here
let's go to the Tweet first uh I wrote
this hey Jonathan heilman I know you've
had a rough couple days after Russell
Brand demolished you on real time but
here are five lies on MSNBC in about a
minute and then I added something about
Michael Steele let's just drop that it's
not important for this let's show the
video uh that I link to there because
this was the night we are showing video
right
oh we're not showing the video yeah
no okay we're not going to show you the
video but we did show it yesterday if
I'm not mistaken uh in that video I
showed within one minute on MSNBC five
lies related to the African-American
studies thing and don't say gay and
DeSantis is a fascist and everything
else anyway I called him out on that and
uh well he ended up blocking me on
Twitter let's jump to that first he
blocked me on Twitter so there's that
because all I did was say hey man you
said that nobody lies on MSNBC how does
a corporate journalist react to you well
they block you on Twitter and then I
thought all right well there must be
more there must be more that this
heilman guy has done and again I don't
really care about this guy other than he
now stepped into the the war right he
stepped into the culture wars and he was
not armed properly now you know he
blocked me okay Big Damn whoop it
doesn't matter but here he is in 2019 on
MSNBC uh claiming that Elizabeth
Warren's DNA test proved that she's
Native American because she was
confident of what the answer was going
to be and she's finally telling him shut
up you know here's and here's some
science for you buddy I know you don't
understand how DNA works but take a look
at this but is she is she sort of is she
out trumping Trump she's trying to do a
couple of things here okay to be clear
what he is defending there is that she
is 10 Generations off being Native
American one 1064.
I'm pretty sure I'm more Native American
than that like if we really started
doing a little digging okay uh
completely ridiculous but Elizabeth
Warren she is a progressive socialist
and he is a progressive socialist
pretending to be a journalist so he's
got to defend her right I'm gonna go out
on a limb here and guess that the
average American just the average
American probably has more Native
American blood than 10 Generations off
okay so it's just this is just
consistent with their insane nonsense oh
Phoenix is actually telling me right now
that's a fact the average American
that's a fact that's incredible the
average American
has more Native American blood in them
than Elizabeth Warren this is a woman
who as she was applying for a job I
believe at Harvard wrote in the thing
that she was Native American so that she
would become a diversity hire she's also
worth about 100 million dollars while
she sends all her kids to private school
wants everyone else to go to public
schools she wants to tax the hell out of
the rich blah blah blah okay you get it
she has a gas stove by the way she's a
real piece of work all right so that was
one heilman thing uh here's another
heilman thing here he is going after
Trump because Trump you remember the
orange guy he said that the Wuhan virus
might have come from the Wuhan lab
in the Washington Post I believe you
know suggests that there is kind of a
systematic effort to try to kind of push
the intelligence Community to find
evidence to support this Theory this
conspiracy theory and you know we've
seen that not just in the Trump
Administration but in the Bush
Administration other administrations
where a politically predetermined
outcome uh ends up putting pressure is
put is applied to the intelligence
community and pressure is put on them so
there's cherry picking there's stove
piping remember those stories around 9
11 and around the Iraq War
um you know this I think that it's it's
it's clearly the case that Trump is
divorced from the facts
Trump is divorced from the facts says
someone on MSNBC because irony is dead
but let's just keep wrecking this guy
and you know what we're not going to
talk about him anymore after this he
blocked me on Twitter he's irrelevant so
this will be this is my and I don't
think I've ever talked about him before
this whole thing happened so this is the
end of the John heilman portion of the
Reuben report uh so he lied that native
that uh Elizabeth Warren is a Native
American uh he completely lied that
Trump was with no evidence whatsoever
saying that this thing might have been a
lab leak now we're all coming around to
the idea that it probably was uh here he
is saying that uh Devin Nunes who is a
former congressman from California that
he's a Russian plant question that I
asked Senator Murphy a little earlier
um it's an imposit question and again
one that would have been seemed would
have seemed absurd in almost any other
circumstance but
Congressman Nunes your chairman it is
suggested by by not by me but by people
who follow these matters closely is this
it could possibly be someone who's
getting compromised by the Russians is
that something you that you consider
possibility I can't speak to his motives
I think he's been compromised by the
White House that is absolutely
incredible when he was on real time he
said we don't lie intentionally show me
a moment where people lie but do you see
the way they they love these linguistic
games he said it's being suggested not
by me but by other people who know about
this stuff
that Devin Nunes might be compromised
and then in the most I mean the irony
it's dead he then is talking
to the farting freak Eric swalwell Eric
swalwell banged a Chinese spy we all
know it it is known by everybody so he's
literally making up that Devin Nunes is
somehow a Russian spy while he's talking
to a guy who banged the Chinese spy
we'll mail that to somebody let's send
that to somebody after the show somebody
wants that crumbled up paper somebody's
gonna get it
anyway there are these brief moments so
you get what happens on MSNBC then
there's NBC and you know MSNBC is their
JV league if you screw up on NBC they
send you down to MSNBC that's how it
works right eventually Don Lemon even
though he's on CNN they'll throw him on
MSNBC at like three in the morning and
he'll be like this is the greatest
promotion ever I don't know I don't know
what that my accent would be completely
anyway here is former New Hampshire
Governor Chris sunundo he went on uh
Meet the Press which is Chuck Todd's
Democrat lie laundering show and sununu
who the machine really wants him and
Larry Hogan to be the republican
nominees by the way I don't know if you
see it this morning Larry Hogan saying
he's out
um we've been trying to get him on the
show by the way because I've been
somewhat critical of him because I think
he's he's just sort of become a nothing
liar we've been trying to get him on the
show we haven't heard back on that but
apparently as of I think yesterday or
this morning he's not going to run for
president he was going to get zero
percent which is why the mainstream
media liked him as a republican there's
nothing more than they like then there's
nothing more they like and a loser
Republican the other one is Chris sununo
now I have nothing against this guy he
seems like a perfectly nice guy I think
he's he's probably like a somewhat
decent moderate which means he can't win
so that's why they put him on these
shows but he did a nice job here pushing
back on Chuck tide so Chuck Todd's going
off on Fox News that's what they do
right there's one mainstream channel
that has a counter narrative so they
have to go after Fox and here's Chuck
basic being like Oh and here's sununu
basically being like Chuck you all suck
what do you think Rupert Murdoch and Fox
News need to do to regain some trust uh
after what we've learned about this and
are you at all concerned you can have an
honest conversation with Fox viewers
oh oh I don't think it's just Fox I I
mean I'll put them in there but all of
media all of Television media and
everyone has to own a little bit uh of
the lack of trust the lack of
accountability it's okay to get
something wrong in the news but you got
to come back and own it and whether it's
fox or CNN or MSNBC or you know whatever
everyone just has to own as a governor I
might try four or five things and if one
or two don't work I'll say hey that
didn't work what about intentionally
lying to viewers we're getting
acknowledge that we can pass the funding
intentionally lying to viewers though
that that to me seemed to cross the line
can make a mistake but that's that
wasn't a mistake
so explain to me that look I'm not
defending anybody because I think you're
all you're all in the same basket I
really do but I could go to CNN when
they talk when they they're going to
ignore the the hunter Biden laptop story
we could talk about the virus coming
truly coming out of the lab in Wuhan we
could talk about a lot of different
things if you're not owning that you
misrepresented the story whether it was
intentional or not everybody does it and
that's the problem America is losing
faith in media and you guys have a huge
opportunity to regain that but right now
my message to Fox News is build your
ratings build your audience go bigger
because if we don't go bigger as a
Republican party we can't win in
November so I want them to talk to
Independents more not change our values
or who we are or what we're talking
about as Republicans but get more uh
opportunistic about the chance to bring
more people in Studio seems like a
perfectly nice guy so if I was a little
dismissive of him in the lead in there
like seems perfectly nice I'd be happy
to interview him I don't think he will
have any support really if he runs the
media will kind of push him because
he'll sort of be like an ineffectual
Republican you guys get that how that
whole situation works but he did a
really nice job there the line you're
all in the same bucket that's what he's
saying to Chuck Todd you all lie about
everything and then that Chuck Todd with
a straight face has the gall to be like
well intentionally lying that's the line
that's too far which by the way is the
same exact line that heilman used on
Russell Brand Show me an instance where
they intentionally lied and it's like
well I don't have the emails to prove
that you guys didn't know uh that the
very fine people on both sides was a lie
but it was a lie or that Jesse Smollett
was not uh going to be uh what was it he
was going to be hanged by two black guys
who he turns out he hired that you've
lied about everything right I always
give you the list so if you you know the
list all right I don't need to give it
to you every time you guys got the point
but
that's good that's good the fact that
some voices are somehow trickly even
when they bring these people on right so
you got to understand they're bringing
him on to be an ineffectual Republican
that's why they like him but he comes on
and he did the right thing so golf clap
to you sununu pretty pretty good so what
else is happening since they're always
so focused on Fox why is it that they're
focused on Fox well it's sort of like
the Parlor thing remember the Parlor
thing a couple years back before January
6th parlor out of nowhere
which was a Twitter clone got about 23
million monthly active users that's a
huge number and it happened in a very
brief amount of time and they had a ton
of influencer types on the right then
January 6th happens and then the the
mafia I would say it's a mafia move of
Amazon Facebook everybody they decide to
point their guns at parlor and go oh we
need a scapegoat here who can we blame
January 6 on let's literally blow up I
mean they can in effect blow up the
servers Amazon AWS Amazon web services
somebody at Amazon presses a button or
it's a slider on a touch screen or a
lever I don't know what the hell it is
and they can blow up an entire website
that's what they did with parlor that's
by the way Rumble is building massive
infrastructure to make sure that that
cannot happen Okay but that's a that's a
side here but they did that and we are
now finding out that actually what we
knew some of this we knew about a year
ago that it turns out most of the
coordination on January 6 happened on
Facebook but it's odd they didn't blow
up Facebook because Facebook is in their
Mafia right that's like the New York
mafia and the New York mafia is going to
do a lot of bad stuff but they're not
going to kill each other most likely but
they will kill the guy from Jersey who
stumbles in and does something stupid in
this case uh or not something stupid
something that they don't like in this
case it was parlor anyway to relate this
all back to January 6th as you know
Tucker Carlson now has I think 41
000 hours of security footage from the
capitol on January 6th Kevin McCarthy
gave it to him and Dave Tucker's people
have been diving into it now as I said
the other day maybe McCarthy made a
little bit of a mistake here because he
could have just opened it up to
absolutely everybody because then it
would have seen purely non-partisan but
he felt that giving it to Tucker was the
right thing we can all have our own
judgment call on that but mostly what
people are upset by in the corporate
media is that they didn't get it right
like if this had been a Democrat giving
it to CNN nobody would be complaining
but they're very upset that Tucker has
it now Tucker you could say what you
want about Tucker but if you think he's
going out of his way to selectively edit
these videos right now now that's
probably pretty nuts because he knows
that one these they've already been
leaked right you have the 40 000 hours
that means other people have that have
it one way or another one of your
employees sent it to somebody like
they're out there now so if Tucker now
over the course of the next few days is
just going to selectively edit things
for his own narrative he'd be destroying
his own career I don't think Tucker is
that stupid anyway uh Tucker has been
releasing some interesting information
from these 40 000 Plus hours uh here he
is showing that the police basically
acted as tour guides for several of the
January 6th people who got into the
capitol but particularly the shaman
remember the shaman with the crazy hat
and the face makeup and the whole thing
watch this this is wild dangerous
conspiracy theorist dressed in
outlandish costume who led the violent
Insurrection to overthrow American
democracy for these crimes chansley was
sentenced to nearly four years in prison
far more time than many violent
criminals now receive what did Jacob
chansley do to receive this punishment
to this day there is dispute over how
chansley got into the Capitol building
but according to our review of the
internal surveillance video it is very
clear what happened once he got inside
virtually every moment of his time
inside the capital was caught on tape
the tape show the Capitol Police never
stopped Jacob chansley they helped him
they acted as his tour guides here's
video of chansley in the Senate chamber
Capitol police officers take him to
multiple entrances and even try to open
locked doors for him we counted at least
nine officers who were within touching
distance of unarmed Jacob chansley not
one of them even tried to slow him down
chancelly understood that Capitol Police
were his allies video shows him giving
thanks for them in a prayer on the floor
of the Senate watch
contrast the reality of what Jacob
chansley did in the Capitol building on
January 6th okay so you really gotta
understand this guy is now in jail for
four years I have no doubt he's been
been treated unbelievably horribly he's
not the only one in jail obviously but
officers are literally escorting him
looking for doors to open I mean when
you see that moment where the guy turns
the doorknob and then they see that that
door's locked they unlocked other doors
from they they escorted him into the
chamber right why didn't when those nine
cops and he just walks by him why didn't
anyone be like oh sir you can't uh walk
in here you can't do that sir we're not
gonna do that we do love the hat but you
can't come in here but they don't do any
of that because this was all I don't
know that it was an inside job exactly
but who was giving them the orders to
stand out why were so many barricades
pulled away and doors opened for these
people do you really think as AOC and
Chuck Schumer and Nancy Pelosi have
stated that that guy was a dangerous
insurrectionist and that the United
States government was in danger of
falling within a couple hours nobody had
plans nobody had weapons uh for the most
part they didn't even vandalize the
freaking place I think somebody might
have taken Nancy Pelosi's keyboard okay
you can't steal things right but that is
the people's house and if I wonder I
honestly wonder if I was at the Capitol
we're going to DC in a couple weeks
we're arranging an actual tour but I
wonder if I walked over to the Capitol
and the door was just open
and then the police was standing there
and I was like can I go in and he was
like yeah of course you'd go in and I
just started wandering around like am I
breaking the law at that point this is
all completely nuts but let's just do a
little bit more on this because Tucker
is releasing this stuff and and I think
I do want to mention one other thing
this is going to be a little bit like
the Twitter files no matter how much
truth comes out right now right so with
the Twitter files we found out that for
sure the government was colluding with
Twitter activists to silence people and
Twitter was paying sorry the government
was paying Twitter to do it now I don't
know that that woke anybody up I think
it woke it strengthened your wake up
right but did but how many new people
did that actually wake up and this is
the problem with the silo thing that
we're going to have to continually
figure out and what I fear is going to
happen with this Tucker thing is a whole
bunch of us who thought that this was
kind of bunk from the beginning and
nonsensical and you know my policy on
January 6th I basically never I never
talked about the coverage of it and I
didn't even want to talk about the event
because I just thought it was it was
just more nonsense like impeachment six
of trump and all of those things but
more and more videos coming out and the
question is will this wake up anybody on
MSNBC they'll tell you that it's all
lies and Tucker's selectively editing
the video and a certain amount of people
will just never get anything close to
the truth and if Tucker is manipulating
stuff and and having his own audience
fall for it that's not my position but
if that was the case then we got a
problem there too anyway here is Tucker
debunking this idea that Brian sicknick
who is the police officer supposedly
killed by January Sixers uh that it was
much more nefarious that that's the idea
that it was much more at Affairs than it
actually turned out to be take a look at
this several police officers in the
meantime but Brian's sick Nick should
not be reduced to a prop for the
political Ambitions of the democratic
party he was a human being the facts of
his life matter including how he died
to this day media accounts describe
sicknic as someone who was quote slain
on January 6th the video we reviewed
proves that is a lie here is
surveillance footage of sicknick walking
in the capital after he was supposedly
murdered by the mob outside by all
appearances sicknick is healthy and
vigorous he's wearing a helmet so it's
hard to imagine he was killed by a head
injury
whatever happened to Brian sicknick was
very obviously not the result of
violence he suffered at the entrance to
the capital this tape overturns the
single most powerful and politically
useful eye the Democrats have told us
about January 6th and it was indeed a
lie the January 6 committee knew
perfectly well that Brian sicknick was
walking normally through the cap okay so
look I don't know any more about any of
this than you do and I suspect Tucker
will keep doing this dive but the simple
fact is there are more questions here
than there are answers and how do we
wake up more people let's just do a
little bit more on this this is really
interesting because one of the other
things that that the January 6
commission was doing was they were
really trying to find like an Insider in
Congress a republican Insider that they
could pin this all on there must have
been someone they were working with so
they knew where to enter and all of
those things and the guy they went after
was a guy by the name of Barry
Loudermilk he is a Georgian Republican
congressman and apparently he had given
a tour of the capital to some
constituents the day before which
somehow the January 6 commission used as
proof that he was actually giving the
insurrectionists The Insider view the
day before the whole thing went down of
course that now has been completely
debunked as well well since the war of
1812. at one point the January 6
committee publicly accused Republican
Congressman Barry laudermilk of Georgia
of leading a reconnaissance mission
through the Capitol building the day
before they were looking for some member
of Congress that was involved in all
this the surveillance tape that we
reviewed shows this story is a lie and
the Democrats on the committee knew it
was a lie when they told it
the so-called reconnaissance mission
Democrats alleged was nothing more than
Congressman laudermilk giving a guided
tour to his constituents from Georgia
none of whom were quote insurrectionists
laudermilk didn't even take the group
inside the Capitol Building they walked
through a congressional office building
down the street
you know what's funny this is literally
the exact tour that we took a couple
weeks ago when we were in DC what was
that two months ago we walked through
the Congressional office building we
went through the underground tunnel and
then we did do a tiny bit actually in
the capital but the point is they were
trying to find somebody that they could
see ah see he walked them around and
showed them look there's a window over
there and my God that's a ladies room
and well men can use it too because
we're tolerant or something like that
and that that somehow was leading
everybody into their insurrectionist
moves the next day complete nonsense
anyway one more on Tucker here he is
just kind of leveling kinzinger and Liz
Cheney
with that here's the video doesn't
answer every question from January 6th
far from it but it does prove Beyond
doubt the Democrats in Congress assisted
by Adam kinzinger and Liz Cheney lied
about what happened that day they are
liars that is conclusive and that fact
should prevent them from ever being
taken seriously again
yeah so there's just enough evidence and
we all knew why did I say that I wasn't
going to go back and check the videos
why did I say I wasn't going to cover
January 6 because it was obviously the
hearings because obviously nothing was
going to come of it and it was obviously
partisan and nonsensical and when when
Jim Jordan and a bunch of congressional
Republicans wanted to get on the
committee Nancy Pelosi would not let
them on there right because she didn't
care about the truth right and we also
know that Donald Trump called he wanted
more guards at the Capitol that day and
Nancy Pelosi was the one that said no so
anyway the whole narrative is falling
apart hopefully we can get more people
to understand that and wake up to it and
not fall for the lies but okay let's
turn the worm on this whole thing what
do we do we got some wins in the culture
War you know Chris Rock kind of stuff
but then we got the nonsensical op-eds
in the Washington Post then we have wins
when say Chase Bank is like hey go to
Florida because it's working there but
then we have other losses because we
can't wake up everybody so what do we do
we gotta calmly and clearly State the
case that's what I'm constantly trying
to show you guys because if you do that
that's how you win their their case is
not that good so to send that all the
way back to our cold open today Bernie
once asked what his bait all Bill Maher
said was hey what's the basic thing that
you've been talking about for 30 years
and Bernie folded like a wet paper bag
right so just State what you believe in
clearly uh Jedediah Bilo who's a friend
of mine former actual sane co-host of
the view she's doing a show with
valuetainment right now which is Patrick
David's show I think I'm going to do a
live thing with them in a couple weeks
actually but Jedediah had a nice uh take
on on freedom and the tenuous position
that we're all in unless we do something
about it this is why I tell you people
oftentimes live under the the delusion
that oh where in America and we're safe
by virtue of our constitution we're safe
by virtue of the fact that we're the
land of the free and I'm here to tell
you you're not safe you are not safe
your freedom is not safe because it's no
longer the United States run in the
United States
you have these institutions who wef that
are now running
a bunch of what once were autonomous
countries that are no longer autonomous
yeah that's true right look at the three
years of covid who did we hand our
decision making over to we handed it
over to the who to well to the NIH to
the CDC all of these organizations who
now we know lied about literally
everything and the depressing part is we
know that the next time they do it there
are going to be an awful lot of people
it's going to shock all of us that's
that's the depressing reality no matter
how many people we read bill it'll never
be enough because when they come back
and they lock you down because of
climate change or covid9 or monkey pox
or whatever it might be a whole bunch of
people are going to want to do it again
and they will do it again and Gretchen
Whitmer will be out on her boat eating
caviar while she locks her people down
in Michigan and Gavin Newsom will be
drinking his fifteen hundred dollar
bottle of wine and eating the foie gras
up at uh French Laundry and they will
keep doing it and a certain amount of
people go for it but but to that point
that sliver of people that disaffected
liberal sliver of people who are waking
up we have to convince them that they
can come over and and vote Republican
basically and what a crazy position that
is for a guy like me to have to tell you
but it's the same thing from that clip
that we showed you yesterday from
lizelle the Republican congressman from
New York who almost pulled off the upset
of upsets in the gubernatorial race
against Kathy hokel right he said you
must keep going to those Democrats
because those are the people who might
switch you can't always go to the base
Trump for example really good at going
to the base but he's not bringing in new
people anymore the future Republican
party I think has to be a little more in
line with what DeSantis has done which
is you're getting all of the disaffected
Liberals you're getting the Libertarians
you're getting the all the new incoming
people who are going oh I actually
understand what freedom is and I'm
appreciative that there's a little
Bastion of it right here so how do you
keep getting those red pilled liberals
and those those sort of disaffected
lefties well you got how to keep
allowing for truth to get out there here
was a really nice moment a couple days
ago this is I would say two liberals
this is Joe Rogan and Russell Brand
calling out that unelected bureaucratic
machine that jebediah's talk Jedediah is
talking about related to Bill Gates and
covet and vaxes and more watch the video
we're thinking the best thing might be
this medication but of course you can
vote what you don't want is the who
determining that in the next pandemic
they have the right to implement by
their votes it contained within who
like lockdown measures medication
measures which is something that they're
lobbying for currently I understand less
and less democracy more and more ability
for unelected globalist I would have to
say globalist organizations to assert
political influence over Nations and
that's what we saw here and like when
you know that the who is second biggest
funder is the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation and he invests so heavily
into these facts again like stuff that
gets called conspiracy theory but you
can look at the the evidence is there
Bill and Melinda Gates Foundation
profited millions of dollars on the
vaccines millions millions and millions
of dollars it's all easy to find and
then once he dumped the stock then he
completely changed his narrative and he
started talking about how ineffective
the vaccines were and about how the
virus wasn't as bad as we thought it was
and about it was mostly targeting old
and obese people like this is
wild because this is the same guy that
threw the entire pandemic was talking
about how great these vaccines are and
these vaccines are so effective and they
stop the virus they stop transmission
they stop infection and all that was a
lie and he profited off those lies all
right so this is good stuff guys you may
be watching that going well I know all
this stuff and okay we've been talking
about this for all but you got to
remember Rogan's got the biggest podcast
on the planet his audience is generally
I would say a bit left leaning it's hard
to say now at this point right maybe
it's a little more libertarian but Rogan
himself as far as I know in the last
election didn't even vote right so he he
this guy who's unbelievably influential
I suppose didn't have the I don't want
to exactly say it like this he either
didn't have the balls or whatever it was
he just couldn't do the thing for Trump
right even though he was always
complaining about Biden always
complaining about wokeness all of these
things right he couldn't quite get there
but now actually now that we're into
this Biden term and things have been a
little weird and all the covid nonsense
and the cognitive stuff and everything
else even Rogan now is coming out and
saying that he could do something a
little different this time and I go I
would vote for Trump before I'd vote for
Biden just because the thing with Biden
like he's no he's he's gone like you
know he's gone it's you're going to be
relying on his cabinet and I knew his
cabinet would be this Sideshow
of diversity and which is exactly what
it is I mean let that one person who
stole all the women's clothes that Sam
Brinton we highlighted on the podcast
yesterday like that's a diversity hire
you you just said oh look at this a man
who dresses like a woman and has a beard
and a mustache but also wears lipstick
this is perfect for us I don't give a
what this guy's good at or bad at I
don't give up what their credentials are
this makes us look like we're inclusive
this makes us look like we're on the
right side so let's let's hire this
person and that those are the you can't
have those kind of people running a Ben
and Jerry's you you certainly can't have
those kind of people running the most
powerful government the world's ever
known it's nuts it's nuts so what I
would say to Rogan is better late than
ever right like all good man and these
are the people that we can still get
let's not forget Joe Rogan also fled
California he signed like a 200 million
dollar deal with Spotify then realized
he didn't want to pay the high taxes
probably wasn't thrilled with the crime
and everything else and he moved to
Texas so he's getting it in terms of his
own life and now he's getting it at the
bigger level so you want these people to
be helped and again for whatever my
differences in terms of politics might
be with Russ brand which we will get
into tomorrow live at the local studio
um he's on his way and now we have to we
have to apply some of this into real
politics and how do we solve some of the
stuff and I think you know that there is
a blueprint that is being exported from
this very state that is a working
mine show today guys I would say just
fine a nice follow-up to yesterday's Big
Show uh we got a post game show for you
in just about 51 seconds at
reubenreport.locals.com part one of my
interview live in studio with Carol
Markowitz and Bethany Mandel all about
mamas that have had it with the people
who are coming for their children and
their new book on just that topic is up
right now full things up at locals we
leave you this is a great cold close
we're leaving you with and I'll see
everybody else in the post game
momentarily thanks guys close your eyes
remember what you saw on television
remember seeing those neo-nazis and
klansmen and white supremacists come out
of fields with lighted torches you
remember what the president said when
asked and you had people and I'm not
talking about the neo-nazis and the
white nationalists because they should
be condemned totally their veins bolts
in a specifically no he did not he said
he walked out and he said let's get this
straight the vein bulging on their
screen as they were screaming remember
just close your eyes and picture what it
was their veins bulging their veins
bulging Nazi sympathizers
carrying Nazi
Maine's bulging sir veins bulging veins
bulging how are you baby how old are you
your veins bulging yes they're veins
bulging bulging veins well I'm sick and
tired of Smart Guys their veins is
they're bulgy they're veins and bulging
their veins bulging veins is bulging
bulging pure have you ever heard this
President say one negative thing about
white supremacists have you ever heard
it racism is evil damn it and those who
cause violence in its name are criminals
and thugs including the KKK
neo-nazis white supremacists and other
hate groups that are repugnant to
everything we hold dear as America
[Music]
thank you